cyberpunk is a mature visceral
experience and as such it will let you
explore a variety of different
interactions with the game world and as
you just saw its people mean the job was
a success and V obviously has some money
to burn my balls and I've been a hot
date with my Ripper duck
oh I know meet the doc we pull some
pants on your cool don't get down here
subway entrance put your iron okay
Jackie has just told us to get some big
news for us and we have an appointment
with our refer back to those before we
leave let's take a good look around our
home good morning night city the song on
the radio is by rocker boy Johnny silver
it's part of our creative process to
draw inspiration from the pen and paper
system created by Mike Pond Smith and to
put our own 2077 spin
[Music]
let's go grab our keys okay we'll take
these trusty pistol
and also grab our jacket since cyberpunk
2077 is an RPG the jacket not only
provides us with protective stats like
armor but it also increases our streak
street cred is a form of experience the
player acquires by completing side
missions it is used to unlock new
vendors and content throughout night
city
all right let's go meet Jack these
current apartment is located inside a
mega build a huge building complex that
forms a micro society of its own in this
timeline and technology in the world
have evolved in some ways that seem
familiar when but entirely surprising in
others as an example in this world lab
people pay with Edmonds slang for Euro
dollars we make sure to route every
detail in the world's law so everything
has its purpose and stays believable
a big part of our RPG experience is
having a world that is interactive here
a generic ad has morphed into an
advertisement specifically tailored to
the moment of informing her of the
nearest venues she can purchase the
product in this case it shows us where
to find some Nichola so
electro
this is Wilson one of night city's many
guns we won't be checking his wares but
you can purchase an upgrade your weapons
and gear throughout the city cyberpunk
2077 is set in night cr8 a bustling
metropolis located on the coast of the
free state of north California it's a
dystopian city or violence and
oppression are the norm we are working
hard to make Knight City fully realized
seamless open world with no loading
screens currently we're in watson a
former industrial district where a crime
now mixes with money three times yo it's
a piece of [ __ ] now give it back my
edits
that
give me some truth to that
we've greatly enhanced our crowd and
community systems to create the most
believable city in any open-world games
to date the city streets are bustling
with crowds of people from all facets of
life all living their lives within a
full day and night sight
[Music]
okay there's Jack and finally it's
happening
what's up Jack
Dexter DeSean yeah sound familiar
there was to talk to you
okay you see that caddy need to walk on
over there and get us a job ina
fine I'll meet him talk
via zio rippers it turns out we've
caught the attention of one of knight
city's biggest players Dexter DeSean a
fixer a person who gets things done he
wants to meet up and discuss a job do
let's see what he has for us
yo miss V a pleasure
let's roll
scanning the serious job just now
playing gargantuan compared us smashing
up a scaffold you interested
interested sure tell me more glad to
hear before we get started on this
though I need to be sure sure you all
right
all right and the nature of this test
start in the show
see got a classic tale for you psycho
gang just doing his thing jump the core
convoy got away with these
now I need me that little combat bar
they call it the flat head of course I
got the Eddie's to buy it but me and the
Maelstrom boys ain't the best of friends
no flow to our convo see
who's the woman corporation
she's on the hunt for the dogs who sold
the gang goons info on the convoy got
herself a prisoner their chief suspect
was like 20 hours since the convoy was
jumped and she still don't have me a
guilty party gotta be desperate by now
be wise I think how you could use it got
any questions for me
we're on at all I think time I got to
work beautiful here's hoping my inkling
checks out
so see you at the afterlife soon as the
job's done do good and this will be the
start of a beautiful friendship based on
heaps of Eddie's
it seems dexter has given us a test of
sorts to see if we're a word he wants us
to retrieve a piece of hi-tech combat a
local gang stole from the military
medical will be able to approach this
job from a variety of angles let's try
calling the military to see where that
leads hi
heard you were looking for some tech
let's talk
first exit off skyline going towards the
NID storm channel under the overpass
meet you there
the situation's tricky because the
contract Giver as a corporate agent who
seems a little high strong before we get
down to business it's a great idea to
visit our River
yeah yeah you see this camp I'll get got
a real whack tape change your [ __ ]
life
crime is a common occurrence night city
is not a safe place life here is not
easy
got some juices
your heart chakra looks a little out of
whack babe